hey friends so check this out this is a
1.5 beat weave it is my favorite petrick
that is based around pendulums and it
occupies a very special place in my
heart because it is also the pyric that
I launched this Channel with way back in
2008 when I started up my tech poy blog
but it is also a trick that I have been
exploring in some detail lately with
some more advanced variations so I would
love to go back and show you all some
variations that are specifically geared
towards beginners so let's check them
out Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I'm going to
take you through five of my favorite
variations on 1.5s that are specifically
geared towards beginners before we dive
in though I just want to give a quick
shout out to the Friends of the channel
big thanks to dark monk fire Mecca flow
fests flow toys pyrro Tera light toys
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these amazing
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking at the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- buus friend
of the channel That is Becca becklin
thank you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission all right
so so the 1.5 the venerable poy trick
that first got me into pendulums back
after I'd been spinning for about a year
uh this was a really really fun
challenge to pick up and the thing I
liked most about it was just seeing how
the pohe heads came together almost like
they were kissing at either end of the
trick and it is also a great basis for
starting an exploration of 1.5s in
general because there's a lot of things
out there that you can do with them
so let's drill down five different
variations on this move starting with
the classic itself The 1.5b Weave where
we have our arms separated now part of
what makes this move work is that we're
essentially taking the basic uh kind of
pattern of a three beat weave that is I
take right hand over left hand over
right hand over left hand over like so
and I really really really exaggerate
the movement of whichever hand is going
over so it's kind of like doing a really
really huge exaggerated weave in a lot
of different ways and that does
something really specific for us namely
uh we wind up taking our hand across our
waist and spinning the poy next to our
opposite hip and then when it comes back
around to our native side we have to add
a whole bunch of movement into it and
first we reach back behind us and then
up next to our ears we bring around the
POI forward in that giant pendulum we're
trying to take away some of the momentum
on the POI as our hand goes around on
its own side so you can think of this as
Spin and pendulum Spin and pendulum Spin
and pendulum Spin and pendulum let me
show you that from the side Spin and
pendulum Spin and pendulum Spin and
pendulum Spin and pendulum I'll show you
that from the other side spin
pendulum spin pendulum and the cool
thing is is that when you have both
hands doing that pattern at the exact
same time the 1.5b weave naturally
emerges out of it of course this is the
version where we have our hands
separated which gives us that nice
little spacing where we have the two
pohe heads coming together almost as
though they're kissing which is my
favorite part of it but it also opens us
up to the next pattern on this list
which is we don't have to keep the hand
that is spinning the PO right next to
our hip like so we can have it travel
along with the hand that is performing
the pendulum the biggest difference here
being that we're just trying to make
sure that we don't take momentum away
from the hand that's crossing over our
body we're only taking momentum away
from the PO that's on its own side of
the body so this becomes the difference
between the hands AP part version of the
1.5 and the hands together version of
the 1.5 you can think of of this is
actually having our hands moving back
and forth as though we're like rowing a
boat or our hands themselves are
performing a Tic Tac or two be weave
going back and forth like so you just
want to make sure that you're uh keeping
the hand that is crossing over adding
more momentum to the pois so it still
crosses over top as you do this and of
course it switches the presentation from
the two poy heads coming together almost
like they're kissing to the two pohe
heads kind of locking together out to
the side almost like uh a pacman mouth
closing
up and of course uh one of the things
that you can do with this variation is I
can actually uh take the hand that is
spinning the POI over it and sneak it
underneath the opposite hand now this is
literally the exact same trick as this
where we keep the hands together the
only difference is that I'm now looking
for that weird little spot where I can
stick the hand that is crossing over
underneath the other hand and it makes
the presentation on this I think just
look a little bit cooler because it kind
of suggests working through a 5B weave
instead of a 3B weave but fundamentally
it's exactly the same thing as this
version of the 1.5 it just adds an
additional layer of Interest by making
our hands interact in a more specific
way I think it's pretty cool all right
all right two variations on the 1.5 be
we've down so far so now I'm going to
take you into the butterfly 1.5 this is
the trick that first started off my
Channel all those years ago at least I
think it is it's either that or it was
in the first couple months that I was
running it but um this was really the
first po trick that I learned that I
felt like I was doing some more
challenging and interesting stuff with
and to break this up into his component
pieces uh our hands are moving moving
around in Split time opposites in like
uh kind of an extension here uh my right
hand is going around clockwise my left
hand is moving around counterclockwise
and of course we want to make sure that
they are meeting together towards either
side of my body now the pattern that
each hand is doing individually looks
like this I am taking my right hand down
across my hips to get to the left hand
side and as I do so I spin the PO
clockwise once down near my hips and as
it goes out to the side that's where I
start taking the momentum away from it
and then taking it up and over back over
to the right so I take it down and
around and spin it and then out to the
left before dragging it back to the
right so it's a drag to the right a spin
to the left drag to the right Spin To
the Left drag to the right spin to the
left like so the left hand does the
opposite pattern there's a spin going to
the right and a drag back to the left
spin going to the right drag bag back to
the left and when I put these two
together I wind up with this very cool
pattern where rather than having the two
po kissing each other as they meet in
the middle they seem to be shearing past
each other I think it just creates a
more Dynamic shape personally but uh
your mileage may
vary now of course just as I shared with
you all uh a kind of slightly different
presentation of the first 1.5 in this
video I'm also going to share a slightly
different presentation of this one too
if you look back at those early videos
you'll see that there's a bunch of
places where I'm not quite sure what
presentation to give to this and there
are times where rather than having my
hands moving around in big circles past
each other like so I'm more taking them
around in half circles to either side of
me which you know I I think it has its
merits but I think one of the best
things that this does is it starts
setting us up for what happens if we
start bringing those half circles closer
and closer together towards our body
Center here because eventually we can
get to the point where we're doing the
same pattern but our hands are just
moving up and down in straight lines and
this is where I think this pattern
really really really shines because it
starts turning it into something that
looks more like a stacking pattern so
all I'm doing now is I'm bringing my
hands up and down as I'm performing that
same beat on the bottom pendulum across
the top beat on bottom pendulum across
across the top again beat on bottom
pendulum across the top beat on bottom
pendulum across the top I'm just doing
it with both hands at the same time like
elevators going up and down
um you can work with either presentation
that you want this is probably better
for performance situations since it eats
up more room but this definitely creates
opportunities to play around with floats
and the like um but as beginners I think
probably this is where you're going to
want to start and this is where you're
going to want to get to as you Branch
out into more into some more advanced
things all right so for our final
pattern here uh I'm going to share
something with you that I have seen
countless people over the past few years
independently discover and everybody
thinks that they're the first person to
do it and uh you can find this in one of
my first tech blogs back in 2008 and it
is the behind the back 1.5
this Beast right here which I absolutely
hate doing because behind the back
tricks are really difficult for me um I
have very very short arms and that makes
these very challenging to do um you'll
note that I having to really really
really pivot my upper body back and
forth to avoid having the poy hit my
hips on either side of my body here not
a fun time for me but it still looks
cool in its own right it's still that
pattern of The 1.5b Weave where
whichever hand is the native hand
reaches up to perform that pendulum
above the hand that is sticking close to
the hips unfortunately unlike our uh 1.5
beat weave going not behind the back
there is not a version of this that
involves keeping the hands together
because of course uh our arms don't
quite bend that way but uh it's still a
pattern worth knowing I will confess
that it is certainly more in the
beginner to intermediate side of things
rather than purely beginner but that
doesn't mean that it isn't still fun
hopefully for people who have longer
arms than myself um it's not going to be
that different from learning how to do a
behind the back weave which I will go
ahead and leave a link to a tutorial on
how to do that down in the description
as well as up in the cards but the big
difference of course is just whichever
hand is going to be on top is the one
that's going to reach up and around in a
very big circle and switch its po to
performing a pendulum instead of
spinning like
so goodness awesome so I hope you
enjoyed my list please make sure to like
comment share and subscribe to help
other people find this video and of
course to help my channel grow
[Music]
this video would not be possible without
my amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much you
all rock and if you out there watching
are not currently supporter but you'd
like to become one you can do that by
heading on over to my patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor Po and signing up
there you can get access to a whole host
of awesome rewards but even better than
that you'll be helping me out in my
mission to bring po spinning and flow
Arts to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if you
want to go deep down the rabbit hole and
find out just how weird poy 1.5s get I
did a video a couple years ago detailing
a theory that brings together a whole
bunch of different poy tricks that we
don't normally think of as being 1.5s
but I think that we ought to I'm going
to go ahead and link to that video down
in the description as well as up on
screen thanks so much for watching make
sure to get out and flow yourself today
and I'll see you with a new video real
soon take care now peace